(soft music)
Dr. Blackwelder
is an Associate Professor
and the Director of Geriatric Education.
He's also the Director of Community Geriatrics
at the Medical University of South Carolina.
And he is going to begin a series
of three presentations on caring for those who are maturing.
Thank you very much, sir. I appreciate you being here.
Thank you. Dr. Weismiller.
So I'm Russ Blackwelder, thank you for your attention.
If you only see pregnant women
or if you only see pediatric patients,
anybody in the room that applies to?
Then that means we have a room full of geriatricians,
'cause that's who we're seeing, right?
Dr. Weismiller has a good quote,
I don't know if this is his original saying
or if he took it from somebody,
but "a good geriatrician stops more medications
than they start."
I mean, that sums up my three lectures.
Okay, so nothing to disclose.
I am at the Medical University of South Carolina
where my practice is in
what has traditionally been
called a continuing care retirement community.
So we have independent living, assisted living,
we have long-term care, we have rehab, short stay rehab,
and now our group goes to four of these places
and we're growing.
So I do geriatrics on steroids
and we have medical students
and our family medicine residents rotate with us.
And since 2015, since we started,
we've had nine graduates go on to do geriatric fellowship.
Which is pretty impressive
because this year in the match for geriatrics,
they only filled something like 27% of the spots.
So whether you like it or not, you're a geriatrician.
Okay, so let's start off with a case.
We have an 82-year-old couple comes to your office
for counsel regarding their living situation.
One of them has advanced cancer
and is ready for additional care either in the home
or in a facility.
They want to know what their Medicare will cover.
These questions will be on the board exam.
The healthcare policy, what covers what?
So which of the following is not true?
People often have to pay out of pocket
for assisted living and long-term care.
Average cost in the US
of a private long-term care room is
over a hundred thousand dollars per year.
Medicare will pay once a medical need
for services is clearly documented.
And D, Medicaid is the only health insurance
that pays residential care costs.
Yeah, C. Some of you answered D, maybe you were thinking
maybe Tricare would cover something.
They do cover some long-term care,
but C, Medicare will pay.
That's not true. Medicare will not pay any long-term care
or assisted living cost.
Medicare, we'll get to this in a second,
will pay for short stay rehab.
We'll get to the criteria for that in a second.
Otherwise, most folks, if they have a health insurance
that's paying for residential care cost
are likely using Medicaid.
Okay. Private insurance for long-term care insurance,
that was a big product 20 years ago or so.
They made a lot of actuarial mistakes with that.
So it's a pretty tough product to get anymore.
Not quite as good of a product as it used to be for folks.
So Medicare Part A, that covers skilled nursing,
short stay rehab, home health, hospice
and hospital.
Okay, that's Part A.
For skilled nursing,
for somebody to go, let's say they're in the hospital,
they have a qualifying stay and then they go to rehab.
This changes depending on the type of Medicare somebody has,
but typically that covers full price for that rehab,
days one through 20.
And Medicare is paying a per diem to the facility
and everything comes out of that per diem,
therapy costs, medications, food, nursing care.
Then days 21 through 100,
the person either has a copay of 20%
or if they have a secondary insurance
that oftentimes picks that up.
Okay? If you have any residents in here,
folks that just recently graduated,
this applies to those people you sit
and you wait for the person
to leave the hospital to go to rehab.
When they finally get there,
that's what this applies to. Okay?
That mythical rehab place,
the patient never seems to get to.
Hospice, also Part A.
Life expectancy six months or less,
that's also paid in a per diem.
Really nice benefit for, there was a study a few years ago
that even depression rates for family members
of the deceased were lower if they had hospice.
Because hospice will provide bereavement services
for 11 months after that loved one away, okay?
Part B, Part B covers all their outpatient office visits,
ambulance and DME equipment.
Part C, usually these are managed care plans
like Medicare Advantage, those type of things.
Traditional Medicare doesn't cover vision or dental.
For a lot of Medicare Advantage plans,
they'll include that.
They might have silver sneakers benefits, you know,
gym memberships, those type of things
that potentially people can get.
Also, if you have patients come in who are just turning 65
and they ask you, you know, we've got all these tons
of Medicare plans
and options to sign up for.
If they can afford it,
it's probably best to get the best plan they can get,
because it's much harder as you get older
to increase your level of coverage.
You've gotta go through extra steps
to get a quote/unquote, "better plan."
Much easier to drop.
So if people ever come in
and want your advice on that, tell 'em
to go as big as they can.
That'll help 'em in the long run.
And then of course D, D is easy. D is for drugs. Okay?
Medicaid varies state to state
based on modified adjusted gross income.
Good many folks have Medicare
and Medicaid as they get older.
Now our next question, you're called
to admit an 85-year-old man for UTI by the emergency room.
His daughter is present
and asked about placement to a skilled nursing facility.
To qualify for skilled nursing,
the patient must meet which criteria?
Inpatient status, admitted for two nights.
By being admitted to the hospital, he qualifies.
Observation status
and admitted for at least three nights.
Or D inpatient status
So let's see how we did.
This is gonna shock you, but this is clear as mud.
Oh, y'all did pretty well. That's good.
Here's why this is clear as mud.
If you read the Medicare guidelines,
it says you can qualify if your inpatient status
and you're in the hospital for three days.
Hold on. But the day
of discharge doesn't count as one of those three days.
So effectively you have to be there for three midnights.
I wish they could just say that,
but that's how you interpret it.
Okay? Which is tough
because to qualify for inpatient status, that's somebody
that you expect to be there at least two midnights.
So those don't really add up, right?
Those don't match each other.
There's always legislation percolating around to get rid
of inpatient and observation status.
That hasn't happened yet. Okay?
All right. Now we've got an 80-year-old man referred
for evaluation, possible depression,
accompanied by his wife,
who describes how much more difficulty ambulating he's had
since he had an esophagectomy for cancer 18 months ago.
Medications include hydrochlorothiazide, lisinopril,
risperidone, metoclopramide, and valproate.
On exam, flat affect, blinks little rocks slowly back
and forth in his chair when asked to stand
but unable to propel himself to a standing position.
When helped up to a standing position,
he has trouble initiating his gait,
takes a few small steps and freezes.
You've got that picture of a person, they're in your office
with the wife to see you.
Which of those is gonna be your next step?
Yeah, there you go. Remember that.
The next thing is board review questions
for geriatrics are usually pretty straightforward.
And again, good geriatrician stops more than they start.
This person's having signs of Parkinsonism,
largely because of all of these medicines
which can contribute to that. Okay?
So here's some Parkinsonism pearls, you know,
don't overlook the medicines they could be
causing this side effect.
Atypical antipsychotics are big culprits.
And if you get a board exam question,
we'll get to this later.
I mean the right answer is for this to say,
really bad agitation in a demented patient,
we want avoid antipsychotics.
We'll get to that later, right?
But real life isn't black and white.
So let's say you've got a person admitted
with Lewy body dementia and they're pulling out lines
and throwing knives and all kind of crazy stuff, right,
that we've gotta control. People aren't safe.
The right answer,
this would be a really good board exam question,
and you have to use an antipsychotic,
which one is gonna be the safest one?
Probably Quetiapine.
I mean you see the others on there.
Pimavanserin is FDA approved for Parkinsonism,
hallucinations and psychosis.
Cost would be a factor.
And then clozapine also potentially is a choice,
but then you've gotta be signed up for the REMS program
to be able to prescribe that.
So less extrapyramidal side effects
with those three at the bottom.
More pearls. These are symptoms.
Things that you'll see.
Another common thing in our facility
that people say that really tips us off
or you know, if they're walking into your exam room
and they get to the threshold of the door
or they get to the threshold of an elevator
or those kind of things and they have just a tough time
crossing that threshold, that's associated with Parkinson's.
Okay? Has your voice changed over the past few months?
Okay. Get really tired walking to the mailbox.
These type of things. Really, you know,
I've had people before, they love writing thank you letters
and Christmas cards and now they can't do that
because handwriting is so hard for them,
or they write so small people can't read it.
All those type of things.
'Cause we can potentially help somebody.
This is something that we can do as we put in
that neurology referral and those type of things is go ahead
and potentially start treatment on carbidopa/levodopa
and see if somebody gets a benefit from it.
There you see some things to take home
and could be on your board exam to help folks.
Carbidopa/levodopa is the most effective for older adults
for those symptoms.
There are very few things in medicine
where folks will hug our necks.
This is potentially one of 'em
if you help somebody 'cause they get on treatment
and it really, really helps them
and they feel so much better
and they think you're a magician.
That's nice. Okay.
So what we want to watch against is using things
like dopamine agonist and some of these other things
that are commonly used for Parkinsonism.
Different thing if you're treating somebody
who's 50 years old versus somebody who's 85.
Okay? My third lecture is gonna get into why that matters
in drugs and how they affect older adults.
I tell our medical students,
whenever I ask a question, no matter what it is,
just go ahead and say anticholinergic side effects.
That's probably the right answer. Okay?
Same principles here.
All right. You see an 80-year-old female complains
of difficulty getting comfortable
and sleeping at night.
On exam, you find the patient's nail beds
appearing like the following image.
Okay? Tough time, getting comfortable at night.
There's the nail beds.
Treatment of which of the following is likely
to relieve the patient's symptoms,
including the shape of the nails.
Yeah, very nice. Presumably that patient was complaining
of restless leg syndrome associated with iron deficiency.
You fix the iron deficiency, you can fix the restless legs,
which is wonderful because the treatment options aren't
that great in older adults. Okay?
Now we've got an 87-year-old nursing home resident
returns from the hospital
after treatment for a wrist fracture
where she was also treated for a UTI.
Completed course of antibiotics and takes PRN oxycodone
for pain.
Now has frequent incontinence of small volumes
of liquid stool, afebrile, what's your next step?
Antibiotics, opioids, now small volumes
of liquid stool, afebrile.
This is a common board question.
Patient has a fecal lith, okay?
And that small volume of liquid stool is coming around that.
What you really need to treat is constipation.
Okay?
Two days later, severe diarrhea and abdominal pain,
temperature of 101 Fahrenheit, white counts elevated.
You get a C.Diff., titre, positive.
What are you gonna treat with, of those options?
Yeah. So right now we could use vancomycin as first line,
125 would be the right dose.
A lot of you are thinking,
well the IDSA also recommends fidaxomicin as first line.
You are correct. Vancomycin is potentially an option.
Fidaxomicin also, we have to worry about cost,
if insurance will pay for it.
The data suggests we probably do have lower recurrences
and better initial treatment with fidaxomicin,
which is bacteriocidal as opposed to vancomycin
which is bacteria static. Okay?
Common cause of severe irreversible loss
of visual acuity in older adults
is age-related macular degeneration.
If you get a question on this, dry is more common.
Wet is more severe.
Wet are the patients who will go to ophthalmologist
and get injections in their eye,
which sounds terrible to me.
I mean, I had LASIK surgery when I was in college
and I went in there and they gave me a teddy bear
and I thought, what are you doing?
I was so glad I had that teddy bear.
Okay, so remember this affects the central vision, okay?
That's where the macula is.
Ophthalmology might give them the Amsler grid
and they'll say, call us and watch out
when that center, all those lines in the middle get wavy.
That's macular degeneration. Okay?
What causes that type of vision loss?
I made it quick 'cause the answer was on the slide,
I realized.
Peripherally that vision was pretty blurry
for those of you that didn't catch it.
Yeah. Remember macular degeneration is central,
glaucoma is peripheral, okay?
Macular degeneration is gonna be more common.
Glaucoma, that's that typical optic neuropathy.
Usually increased intraocular pressure,
which we can measure. Okay?
So keep in mind the differences of those two.
Now a nurse from local assisted living calls us
about an 88-year-old with severe wet macular degeneration.
Patient just told the nurse about seeing shapes
and unicorns near the doorway.
Okay? Patient doesn't seem bothered
and there are no other new complaints.
Okay? What's our next step?
Yeah, reassurance and education. This is not that uncommon.
I'm seeing more and more patients too that will come
to us in rehab where they move into assisted living
and they tell me, they say, "Oh,
I've got Charles Bonnet syndrome," which can happen in folks
with severe vision loss. Okay? 10 to 13%.
Think of it like a phantom limb syndrome for the eyes.
I mean, I've had patients that say, oh yeah, really,
unicorns and rainbows and bright lights.
And they say, "Oh yeah, just walk through it.
No big deal."
I had other patient that said,
"I look out the window and I see a bunch
of Santa Claus people with really long beards."
Doesn't bother 'em. Okay? Just reassurance.
All right. Presbycusis reduction of what type
of hearing loss? Which is also the most common type
of hearing loss in older adults, to give you a hint.
Yeah, higher frequencies.
So don't yell at your older adults.
'Cause when we yell, our voice gets higher.
So try to talk lower. Okay? They'll hear you better.
Now we'll get into this a little bit,
but I mean hearing is a really big deal for older adults
and especially for preventing cognitive impairment.
Okay? Really, really, really need
to be paying more attention to hearing as people get older
'cause it's such a risk factor for developing dementia.
All right? Now we got a 78-year-old woman,
history of OA, comes to your office, four week history
of early morning shoulder and hip discomfort.
Labs are normal except the ESR of 52. Okay?
Which is elevated.
What rheumatologic condition associated
with this patient's primary diagnosis is she also
at risk of developing.
So she had a history of OA came in with shoulder
and hip worsening pain in the morning.
So this is asking which one associated with
what you think the patient has
is she also at risk of developing?
Yeah, very good. The one at risk of is Giant Cell Arteritis.
It's close overlap with polymyalgia rheumatica,
which the patient likely has.
Rare in younger people.
Average age is about 70.
That bilateral aching morning stiffness,
two of the following three that on there said rate elevated.
This is also one of those like patient will hug you,
they're so excited, they feel better conditions.
Could you get 'em started on steroids,
and they're gonna feel remarkably better.
Okay. PMR is lower dose steroids.
Giant Cell Arteritis is higher dose. Okay.
If you're concerned about Giant Cell Arteritis,
temporal arteritis, go ahead
and start 'em on the the steroids.
Okay. Biopsy can still be positive.
Also, more and more centers are doing ultrasound,
which can really save the trouble of that biopsy,
which can be pretty disfiguring
and it's not always easy to find somebody to do it either.
Okay, so go ahead and get treatment started.
Oh, I like this. I like this case discussion.
Alright, get called from assisted living again.
Oh, let me also say,
'cause I know somebody's gonna ask about this.
How long do you treat for PMR and Giant Cell Arteritis?
It depends. Treatment's gonna take a really, really,
really long time, potentially up to a year
and you're gonna have to really monitor patient symptoms,
and also that sed rate.
Some guidelines will say you come down
by like one milligram, you know, just slowly.
You know, I don't necessarily have to be
that conservative about it,
but you really, it takes a while.
Okay. You do it too fast, you risk relapse. Okay.
Alright. Get a call from the assisted living
patient had syncope getting up from the table after lunch.
They're on hydrochlorothiazide, lisinopril for hypertension.
When they finally get to her, there's the blood pressure.
Oh, sorry. Otherwise you check back in the chart.
Blood pressure's been consistently kind of
around the 150 mark when you look in the review,
the record, okay?
Getting up after lunch, passing out, oh,
we get called about this a lot.
Remember I'm from Charleston, South Carolina. Okay?
This is more common with high carb meals.
All right. Our folks are having, you know,
sweet tea biscuits, fried chicken.
Okay? All the blood rushes to the gut.
Gut's really happy.
Then they try to get up
and the brain's like, you forgot about me.
All right. This would be a good board question too.
Not an uncommon thing in your older adults.
Ask them when they passed out, if they come in
'cause of syncope, okay?
Can be prevented by smaller meals.
Gotta be really, really careful going
from sitting to standing.
Maybe sit there and talk to their friends
and gossip a little more before they get up from the table
to go back to their room.
Those kind of things.
And there are my answers.
Thank you very much, Dr. Blackwelder.
(audience applauding)
(soft music)